e
the first item of business is the
consent calendar I'd entertain them is
there anybody who wants to remove
anything from the consent calendar uh
before we do that uh we need to approve
the minutes from last meeting oh sure
I'll move to approve the minutes it's
been move by setting along to approve
the minutes so I have a second second
and by uh representative Maguire any
discussion on the minutes seeing none
all those in favor say I all those oppos
nay the eyes that minutes are approved
um yeah um representative will seat for
um representative Lynn representative
hackin Phillips thank you Mr chair um
consent calendar anybody have anything
they want to take off the consent
calendar seeing n entertain a motion to
approve the consent calendar moved by
represent Schmidt seconded by represent
of lay on is there any further
discussion on the consent
calendar seeing none all those in favor
say I I all oppos nay the eyes haven't
consent calendar is adopted next up
we're moving to the regular calendar the
item a um number
safety uh so this proposal is on the
missing adult program and missing
vulnerable adult alert program these
rules are adop or adoption so their new
rules to implement RC
106j which was amended back in
2016 the only comment I have on this
proposal is there is a question of why
it took the department so long to adopt
these rules um as they were statutorily
mandated
to would you like to respond to that
question why it took so
long could you hit the button uh so red
light com Sun good morning chair good
morning committee members thank you for
having us uh my name is evoa I'm with
the legal unit uh I am the legal
coordinator uh and with me is Sergeant
mallerie Litman the New Hampshire State
Police uh the question is a valid one uh
I will be 100% transparent I have just
started I'm about two months in to this
job so I am catching up as well as to
why it took so long for it to get in
front of you and to become a rule from
my understanding uh it did go through
the process of trying to get here right
now
uh unfortunately due to staffing issues
and then covid and then a a couple more
staffing issues by me um it it did take
longer than it should
have questions from the committee seeing
n entertain on a
motion move to approve it's been moved
by representative groy to approve um 144
do I have a second second it's been
second by sen on the ward any further
discussion on 144 seeing none all those
in favor say I I all those oppose nay I
have it 144 is adopted thank you next up
is the pesticide control board item
number 146 aquatic application of
pesticides yeah so um this proposal
makes amendments to the rules on the
Aquatic application of pesticides there
are a lot of editorial comments and a
few unclear editorial comments that
really do need to be addressed but um no
conditional approval request has been
filed
there is one unclear comment in
particular to bring to your attention
and you'll find that on the top of page
20 of the meeting
packet so what's happening there in the
rule is that the agency has issued a
special permit for the application of
pesticides but the applicant decides
that they need to postpone the pesticide
treatment and in that case the applicant
must notify the agency the rule says
that if the division finds as a result
of the postponement of the pesticide
treatment that adverse effects on human
health and the environment are likely
that it may reconsider its decision on
the special permit but the rule does not
describe even at a high level how the
division will make the decision to
change the permit's terms it doesn't
describe um what they will be
considering or whether the division will
mandate that the applicant actually
perform the pesi pesticide
application so um I did have an email
conversation with the agency and um the
department states that in the past 16
years they haven't had this situation
happen and so they um don't really have
any criteria that they um want to put
into the rule so um I do think though
that the rule really you know ought to
say that the vision shall reconsider the
special permit instead of May reconsider
but um even if they cannot Place
criteria and the rule to describe you
know what they will be looking at and um
what they will do around on that uh
special permit but anyway that's the um
only um substantive comment to bring to
your
attention chman please David rouso with
New Hampshire division of pesticide
control under the Department of
Agriculture markets and food and I'm
representing the div uh pesticide
control
board so we can certainly um if if it's
okay to respond yeah um we can certainly
take those comments and provide an a a a
revision to to that section of the rules
to either
um identify the criteria that already
exists when a special permit is issued
initially um and certainly change that
question so it says if the St could show
us where the I think they did change
sorry about that so it says say that um
as a result of the postponement of
treatment adverse effects on human
health and the environment are likely it
shall after a hearing reconsider its
original decision I'm sorry so I
misspoke there but um I don't know
whether or not they you know can add any
additional language to kind of you know
give some broad criteria here or not um
you could perhaps postpone and allow
them to do a conditional approval
request um your deadline isn't until
March
25th representative L uh thank you Mr
chairman and thank you for being here
with us um part of my question around
this is if it's postponed for only 5
days or 30 days there may not be a need
to reconsider the decision but if it's
postponed for 180 days um there may be
and my question is if you reconsider it
if it's based on environmental factors
changes to rules or laws since it was
implemented and to just understand what
that change is so that there could be
consistency and um predictability for
so it sounds like the agencies would be
okay with the postponements we don't
have to act on this we have another we
could we could take it up in our March
meeting to give you time to respond to
the comments and make additional changes
is that acceptable to the agency
definitely thank you so i' entertain a
motion to postpone been moved by
representative Leon second and by
representative McGuire to postpone item
146 till the March meeting any further
discussion seeing none all those in
favor say I I all those oos nay and
we'll see you next month thank
you next up is the board of mental
health practice item
[Music]
number2 yeah so um the oplc has uh
requested uh that this item be postponed
to the April meeting so that the board
can uh vote on a conditional approval
request uh to address all the comments
there aren't a ton of comments on it um
the board is not meeting in February so
the request is to postpone this to April
um like I said they're not meeting um
this month and their next meeting is
actually scheduled for March 21st which
is the same um date as this committee's
meeting so um if the Jael card agrees to
this request it will need a waiver of
its deadline to act which is um March
25th um in order to hear this proposal
in April so Iain a motion to Grant a
waiver and postpone the item um given
the comments of the
removed by representa Maguire second by
representative hacken Phillips any
further comment yes please um yes thank
you Mr chairman I'm just concerned that
they're not meeting regularly enough
especially if um oplc is sending this to
them as a courtesy it would be very good
for them to meet frequently enough in
order to review the rules and so I'm
concerned that they met I think 18 times
last year and now they're skipping a
February meeting and um I'd just like
them to be mindful of the deadlines
moving forward and meet so that they can
re they can review
these Doug I just asked you to take that
to uh commissioner
um for got I remember D jurus and and
just let her know the comments to the
board all we all those in favor of
postponing waiver say I I all those
opposed nay the items postponed and the
waiver is
granted next up is Department of Revenue
Administration item number 164 for
business profits
tax now you got my
attention so the agency did submit a
conditional approval request which
addressed um the majority of my
substantive comments however there is a
remaining issue regarding the forms the
agency does have an exemption under RSA
541a 21 VA and RSA 21
j3a that exempts the requirements on the
forms from having to comply with the
manual and um the typical things we look
for when it comes to uh forms and the
rule text however
our staff has come to the conclusion
after a legal analysis that this does
not exempt them from not having the
requirement to complete a form in their
rule text so when the agency submitted
this proposal they did submit number of
forms some of them um it has turned out
is Incorporated in other chapters of the
rules which are fine they're just kind
of given for context but some of the
forms are mentioned in the instructions
of forms that are required in the rule
text but they themselves are not
required in the rule text so that's
where we're having a bit of a issue in
that we think that it is um a
legislative intent issue to not include
those forms in the rule text so the
agency and I have had conversations they
are willing to do an amended conditional
approval to address that and get those
forms into the rule text which would
address the issue um the committee's
deadline on this isn't until March 31st
so you would have the ability to review
that amended CA at the March meeting
thank
you good morning Mr chair members of the
committee I'm Jennifer Ramsey I'm tax
policy counsel for the Department of
Revenue Administration um I agree with
the assessment that you've just heard
about the forms we have not typically
included all of the schedules that
support the five basic tax returns in
the rules and that is what we were down
to is a list of all of the supporting
schedules if the committee would like
those incorporated into the rules the
3072 to 07 list the five basic tax
return types um and we could in those
rules add a an addition that said and
any of the applicable schedules so if
the committee would like that we're
happy to do that um we haven't done it
in the past but it's not a
problem questions questions from the
committee so you're amendable to a
postponement of this rule to allow you
to adopt changes into the rule to
address the concerns of yes that's fine
with us so entertain a motion to
postpone rule number
164 uh it's been moved by representative
Leon second by representative Maguire to
postpone item number 164 until the March
meeting so that the agency can take into
account the comments of Staff any
further discussion all those in favor
say I I all those oppose nay see you
you next up is um Department of Health
and Human
Services uh former division of Public
Health Services rule number 172 lead
poisoning prevention and control number
72 so um there are just a few comments
on this one I have a couple of
informational notes and one substantive
comment but my understanding is um
there's a request to postpone yeah when
we take that up I think representative
lon's going to make a request to
postpone this one let's take that up so
we don't waste everybody's time talking
about it only to make a motion to
postpone so okay uh thank you Mr
chairman I'll move to postpone and then
I'll talk to that after seconded I guess
I'll second that can speak to why I want
to postpone thank you um I've received
feedback just some concern concerns
about some of the requirements the dates
um and the impact on business owners and
and people who are impacted by this rule
um I did not have enough chance to see
and make sure that those are actually
all in the statutes um just as we're
transitioning into this and people are
finding information out at the last
minute with Jael car I would ask to
postpone it so that I can go through it
and by next Friday let the department
know if there are any concerns that I
have moving forward um I know this is
sort of asking for Grace to have a last
minute um imposition I am going to start
messaging to people and making sure that
they know the full process to come to
the public hearings so that people are
involved at the appropriate time in the
process um however since we are not up
against a deadline um I would like to
postpone it just to just to ensure that
those concerns are consistent are
concerns with the underlying law and not
with the implementation of the rules any
other comments on any other comments on
postponement
good morning Allison radme administrator
for uh the administrator rules unit at
the Department of Health and Human
Services um I know we have discussed we
are agreeable to postponing however I do
for the record uh want to say that this
rule prior to formal rul making uh went
out to stakeholders three
times um with no responses the public
hearing was had nobody had shown up and
we received no public comment um at all
in this role um the years pass then
we've got gone through this stakeholders
showed up uh we addressed issues um so I
just I want to get that on the record
that we do work with our stakeholders
very diligently especially with this
rule because of how lengthy it is thank
you any other
comment all those in favor there's no
waiver required for this we can make it
in the meeting and still stay within our
timelines as required so all those in
favor of postponement say I I I all
those oppos nay guys have it we'll
postpone till next month
and we'll take up the next item item
236 um the Farmers Market nutrition
program for women and P children yeah so
um this proposal seeks to implement a
new program this farmers market program
that was actually passed in House Bill 2
from
2023 and there are just two issues to
bring to your attention the first one is
that delay and implementation the house
bill 2 was effective in uh July 1st of
so there's been a delay of almost 2
years um the department did state in its
response to that comment that the agency
didn't know that rules were needed but
the statute does clearly direct the
agency to adopt rules so it's not
entirely clear um why the agency didn't
know that it needed some Ru making
around this program uh the agency also
did state that the program is scheduled
to be rolled out this summer so um it
seems like there's a two-year delay um
of that roll out um this the second
comment is an informational note that
lets the committee know um that the
prohibited items the items that aren't
covered under this program those three
items are dried herbs herb plants and
pickled vegetables those are actually
listed in the New Hampshire state plan
and um as prohibited as not being
non-covered they aren't listed in the
federal rag but um the but the Federal
Regulation does allow agencies to
over what to permit so um those are my
only two comments on this
one question uh agency good morning
again uh Allison radme uh administrator
for the administrative rules unit at the
Department of Health and Human Services
and I'm going uh to pass this over to
the program to
address hello my name is Haley mlar I'm
the nutrition service section
administrator in the Bureau of family
and health and nutrition um and I would
like to address uh the note so when the
legislative language was added to House
Bill 2 in 2023 and became law the
department had a staffing transition
within the nutrition service section
during due to this transition
unfortunately the prompt initiation of
rule making was missed and not done on
schedule by the department once the
delay was realized by the depart the
department immediately began the rule um
drafting uh process for this program I
would also like to add that we we had an
lengthy Contracting process we started
that immediately after the rule was
created in July and it took about 18
months to get a contract in place so we
just had our contract fully executed
program any questions from the
committee uh representative mire
sorry yes thank you um Cons considering
that this benefit is between1 and $30
per recipient I'm I feel justified in
saying that the administrative costs
will probably exceed the benefits and
that was one of the reasons we argued we
debated this last
budget repr Leon um thank you Mr
chairman um I'm actually a little
concerned that the herb plants aren't
included I would think that these
programs are supposed to have more
self-reliance and um I'd rather see
people bringing home a basil plant that
they continue to um that they're
continuing to use in their cooking than
just some cut basil leaves I know that's
part of the state plan but um I just
wanted to raise that as a concern
because I think we should be lifting
people up not just making them continue
to keep purchasing
things F questions from the
committee as a former markers as a
former Farmers Market director I think
it's a great program I know we did roll
some of this out with ebts quite a few
years ago and do now include the women
and fit and children is is great to see
citizens using our local farmers for
what they're consuming rather than
stores I agree and if you'd like I to
entertain a motion I'll move to approve
it's been moved to approve there second
second by sen long any further
discussion on uh one
236 see n all those in favor say I I all
are oppos nay the eyes have it thank you
ladies thank you
much next up is the board of natural
scientists it says it's to be postponed
ask questions on the staff um yes so the
uh representative from oplc reached out
and requested a postponement because
they want to work with the board on a CA
request so they're asking to postpone to
the March meeting the committee will
need a waiver because the deadline for
the committee is March 11th all of the
comments I had on the final proposal
could be addressed with a conditional
request it's mostly just discrepancies
between the requirements and the rule
text and the form so very easily fixable
so I would recommend a CA request to
address those thank you Mr chair would
you entertain a motion for waiver and
postponement so waiver and have them
adopt the changes recommended by staff
is that the mo a postponement to allow
them the opportunity to do a conditional
approval request so move so move second
is there any further
discussion seeing none all those in
favor of postponement in waiver signify
by saying I I all those opposed nay the
eyes have it we've granted a waiver and
we postpone till the March meeting next
up is the board of psychologists uh rule
number two uh
234 um temporary license or application
process for those licens in other
states so this proposal is uh has a
unique issue in that when the notice was
published in the register with the
IP it was noticed that this entire rule
was going to be repealed because the
oplc now has the authority to handle
temporary
licenses there was a comment made by OS
staff um as a suggestion to perhaps
reference the oplc rules instead of just
repealing the entire section so at least
then people if they're looking in these
rules could go to the oplc rules the
board did do that and it's our position
that that is covered under the notice
because the notice talks about the
change in Authority however the board
also reinserted paragraph B which it
said it was going to repeal and
paragraph B talks about what
entities um would be allowed to bring
people to New Hampshire in an emergency
and allow those people to practice
without a temporary license for 60 days
there is a statute that allows this the
statute only references two entities but
then gives discretion to the board to
include additional
entities we do not think this is covered
by the notice we don't think the public
had an opportunity to comment on this
particular paragraph um and therefore we
made a legislative intent comment that
the process wasn't properly
followed um at this point I have talked
with board counsel and um they seem to
understand our concern and and the issue
and at this time my recommendation to
the committee would be to do a
preliminary objection based on
legislative intent and allow the board
an opportunity to hold an additional
hearing as I understand there's
precedent for this that this has
occurred before um in order to correct
that lack of public notice and lack of
public opportunity to
comment moved on let's hear from the
agency first before we make
motions good morning Tina Kelly I'm A
rules coordinator for the office of
professional liur and
certification and um it is we've worked
with um the attorneys from admin rules
and with the board's attorney and we're
amenable to um holding an additional
hearing getting public comment and
coming
back thank you so from staff are we'll
do a preliminary objection allow them to
go back correct the deficiency and then
bring the rule forward again correct Mr
chair just a quick question about the
timeline after the second hearing how
much longer do you think it will take to
return to administrative rules or Jael
car for the presentation um if I may so
if you issue a preliminary objection the
board then has 45 days in order to do
their response so they would have 45
days to publish notice in the register
about the hearing hold the hearing and
then provide us the information of what
happened at the hearing um and if they
need additional time to do that they
would have to request a waiver uh from
the
director and the notice period for our
office is 20 days um so they can file we
can get a notice in the register and
then because it's a board their public
comment period can end at the end of the
meeting
so any further discussion now
representative Schmidt I'll entertain
your
motion I still stand by my
motion second so the motion is do a
preliminary OB ction due to the um
issues around the notice for public
hearing and and it's been seconded by
represent group uh is there any further
discussion on this seeing none all those
in favor say I I I all those oppos nay
eyes have it and we have a preliminary
objection you have your timeline to
correct thank you um the objection
response for the Dental Board still
hasn't if you remember we gave them
until April we waved and gave them till
April I know they're still working on
this rule I've had some conversations
about where they are and what they're
doing and there's still negotiations
going on um I do anticipate we will have
this in April um but uh the surgeons and
the board are all working together try
to get a place that meets statutory
intent at the same time satisfies
everybody um any other business to come
before jail car dog we have anything
else we good we are adjourned all
and the continued meeting is cancelled
right